devant le centre de réfugiés sonam 11
ans attend son tour il va devoir
raconter son histoire si le responsable
du centre la juge crédible il aura le
statut de réfugié sinon il peut être
expulsée d'un
tu es déjà allé à l'école dans son
village oui qu'on bientôt deux ans
et que font tes parents ils sont nomades
ou fermier
fermiers
combien départ ont donné ou pas ce site
1500 et
1700 euros cela représente deux années
de revenus pour ses parents
et tu as voyagé tout seul non moi et ma
petite soeur
le dossier de son âme rejoindra cette
étagère lourde de milliers d'autres
histoires d'enfants par venu ici après
des semaines de cavale à la vie à la
mort
certains tombent dans des crevasses et
meurt dans route
certains meurent simplement de froid
c'est un voyage extrêmement dangereux
c'est plein de risques pour les enfants
mais leurs parents pensent qu'il vaut
mieux qu'ils grandissent ici plutôt que
si l'emprise chinoise
ils se disent qu'ici en exil ils vont
pouvoir apprendre la vraie histoire du
tibet découvrir leur culture est resté
devrait tibétains
l'entretien de sonam s'est bien passé il
a convaincu le directeur il a un oncle à
dharamsala ne reste qu'à trouver et il
pourra quitter le centre de réfugiés
il vendait ce livre dans la rue
c
au tibet je vis dans la montagne alors
ce n'était pas trop dur pour moi de
marché
nous les tibétains ont ces escalades et
c'est pas comme les petits chinois qui
se déplace qu'en voiture dès qu'il doit
faire quelques mètres il se met à
chialer
et toi tu n'as pas pleurer quand tu es
parti
non tes parents te manquent pas
je ne veux pas qu'il me manque
en attendant se nomme va s'installer
chez son oncle il est venu tous les
jours pendant un mois au centre de
réfugiés il n'avait pas de nouvelles de
son neveu il a fini par croire qu'ils
avaient été arrêtés
je suis très content
il va pouvoir enfin aller à l'école et
surtout il va découvrir la liberté
première urgence pour son âme prévenir
ses parents qu'il a réussi à passer sont
donc accepte de les appeler malgré le
danger
il affirme que tous les appels d'un
verre le tibet sont écoutés
à l'eau
c'est pour son âme
ouais quant à thiès la ligne a été
coupée
les chinois coupe tous les albums
il écoute toutes les conversations
internationale surtout si ça parle
politique
ensuite ils viennent arrêter les gens
chez eux
à ses parents son âme a promis de
revenir dès qu'il aura terminé ses
études ce qu'il ignore c'est que
derrière lui la frontière s'est refermée